all right guys this is a response to a
viewer who is watching the third step of
my 4x4 Rubik's Cube tutorial which goes
over how to solve the remaining parity
cases in the 4x4 cube so if you look at
the 4x4 cube i'm holding here these two
pieces have basically been switched the
orange edge piece is on the blue side
and the blued edge piece is on the
orange side if you look at the remaining
two sides they are complete this is a
case which you will never see in a 3x3
cube what you do see in a 3x3 cube
however if you look at my seventh step
of the 3x3 tutorial is that you have you
can you frequently actually get a solid
side and you get three in proper edge
pieces on the top layer so what we want
to do is we want to basically get it so
that it looks like a 3x3 cube in the
seventh step so we want to get three
incorrect three incorrect edge pieces
instead of two so what we do is we
basically hold a completed side on the
right because after this we're going to
be able to perform the Allan and in the
Allan you have to hold the completed
side on the right now it doesn't really
matter you can hold it on the left and
then you could do the reverse Allan if
you wanted to but since I taught the
regular Allan I'm just going to go over
how to to get it so that you can use
that move instead so you basically want
to hold a completed side on the right it
doesn't matter which completed side what
we're basically going to be doing is
performing the same algorithm first that
I use in the third step to basically
switch these two edge pieces the top two
opposite edge pieces so what that will
do is it will bring the piece here which
is the orange piece it will bring it on
to the green side and we'll bring that
green piece on to the blue side so we
will have we're going to have three
incorrect edge pieces so let's go ahead
and perform that move so hold that
completed side on the right and you do
inside right face 180 degrees up face
180 degrees inside right face 180
degrees just this face is going 180 so
you have to remember to turn this one
back both up faces 180 degrees
inside right face 180 degrees both up
faces 180 degrees and then just the up
face 180 degrees now you look at the
cube and you'll see that there are three
incorrect edge pieces so now we're going
to do is we're going to hold the
completed side on the right and then if
you look at the three edge pieces what
the Allen does is it makes the edge
pieces the three edge pieces go in a
counterclockwise direction so this one
is going to go here this piece is going
to go here and this piece is going to go
here meaning the green piece is going to
go on the green side the orange piece is
going to go on the orange side and the
blue onto the blue side so we hold that
completed side on the right and we
perform the Allen which is left 180
degrees top face counterclockwise back
face clockwise front face
counterclockwise left face 180 degrees
back face counterclockwise front face
going to go clockwise then the top face
is going to go counterclockwise and then
the left face is going to go 180 so if
you followed that procedure you should
end up with a final complete cube
alright guys so hopefully that helped
out a little bit basically what we did
is that since we had these two edges
which were incomplete we just basically
switched these two so that we had three
and then we were able to solve it just
like a 3x3 cube if you have any
questions you can feel free to send them
to me on YouTube and I'll be able to
give you some advice on that if you have
any problems alright guys hope that
helped